عندما غادر لويس جوزيه موطنه الأصلي
في بيرو للعثور على عمل في بيرو ،
كان يأمل في انتظار الطاولات أو ربما مزج
الكوكتيلات
للسائحين ولفترة من الوقت ،
لكن مع انتشار الوباء ، فرض بيرو
إغلاقًا وفقد وظيفته الآن.
ضحايا يطمعون
في الحكومة
المحلية ويأخذهم إلى حرق جثثهم
،
يلتقط أكثر من 20 جثة يوميًا ، هناك
القليل من الوظائف التي تحمل مستوى الخطر الذي
يواجهه هؤلاء الرجال
كل يوم.
تحمل
تكلفة الدفن عالية السرعة التي
لا يمكن أن يحضرها سوى ثلاثة أفراد من العائلة
وتستغرق 10 دقائق
فقط ، ولا يمكن للآخرين إلا أن يدفعوا الاحترام
تقريبًا
لعائلة أخرى يستهلكها الحزن في
بلد على
ركبتيه وهنا ينتهي بك الأمر إذا كنت
لا تستطيع تحمل تكلفة موقع الدفن
في صندوق من الورق المقوى في محرقة الجثث
حيث لا يتوقف دخان الموت
أبدًا ، معظم العمال
هنا أيضًا من فنزويلا
أورلاندو ، أحدهم يعمل 12
ساعة في اليوم
سبعة أيام في الأسبوع لمقاضاة  pport أطفاله الأربعة في
المنزل ،
أورلاندو مسؤول عن الأفران التي
لم يتخيلها أبدًا
أنه سيرى الكثير من الموت
بحلول الليل لويس جوز وفريقه قد
جمع بالفعل
15 جثة من أحياء ليما الأكثر تضررًا
ولكن اليوم بعيدًا عن
راول كان 63 عامًا
قتله كوفيد في ثلاثة
أيام ، اتصلت العائلة بعربة إسعاف
لنقله إلى المستشفى ،
لكنها لم تصل أبدًا ، لذا كان عليهم ببساطة
مشاهدته يموت
[تصفيق]
في الساعة 11 مساءً ، يتلقى الرجال مكالمة أخيرة
من فيلا ماريا ديل تريو للمستشفى
لديهم  لجمع 13 جثة أخرى
لأن الثلاجات
هنا ممتلئة
أثناء انتظار الأعمال الورقية التي
يحصلون عليها أول قضمة لتناولها في بلدنا
على الرغم من التحديات التي واجهتها ، فقد أخذ جوز لويس
شيئًا إيجابيًا
من هذه التجربة ،
غادر هؤلاء الرجال البلاد بحثًا عن
حياة أفضل
ما زلت آمل في العثور عليه
غييرمو جالدوس لـ cnn lima peru